se siente más joven
como ella millones de surcoreanos acaban
de perder uno o dos años a medida que el
país abandona sus formas tradicionales
de calcular la edad un cambio del que
las encuestas muestran que tres de cada
cuatro personas aprueban están seguros
se siente bien porque para las personas
como yo que se suponía que cumplirían 60
años el próximo año ahora tendrán 58 o
59 Y eso te hace sentir como si todavía
fueras joven
Corea del Sur ha utilizado el método
internacional de conteo de edades para
documentos médicos y legales desde los
años 60 pero para el resto de cosas hay
dos formas con las que cuentan sus años
la primera es contar el tiempo que el
bebé pasó en el útero la otra indica que
todos envejecían un año cada primero de
enero en lugar del día de su cumpleaños
Lo que significa que un niño nacido el
31 de diciembre cumpliría dos años al
día siguiente los legisladores votaron a
favor de adoptar el estándar
internacional contar la edad a partir
del día del nacimiento con la esperanza
de que reduzca la confusión causada por
el uso de diferentes sistemas
Esperamos que las disputas legales las
quejas y la confusión social que se han
causado sobre Cómo calcular Las edades
se reduzcan considerablemente
Corea del Sur es el último país de Asia
Oriental en hacer el cambio siguiendo a
Japón en 1950 y a la vecina Corea del
Norte en la década de 1980